[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا القهر والفقر وصفه
سحريه لرفض الواقع والثوره عليه فكيف اذا
اضيف اليها فكر متطرف لا يقبل الاخر هكذا
تهيا الارضيه الخصبه لنمو الجماعات
المسلحه حتى اذا اشتد عودها شكلت تحديا
للانظمه
والمجتمعات واقع اكثر ما ينطبق اليوم على
مصر التي تشهد عنفا تواجه السلطات فيها
بقبضه امنيه معيده الامور بذلك الى المربع
الاول عن قصد او غير قصد يبقى السؤال من
يدعم هذه الجماعات ومن يسلح ومن هو
المستفيد من بقائها على قيد الحياه فتحي
اسماعيل وتفاصيل اوفا في التقرير
التالي لم تشهد مصر عنفا كالذي يجتاحها
هذه السنوات حتى ان الهجمات ضد رموز
السلطه تحولت الى ظاهره تفرض نفسها على
مراكز البحث ويخصها الخبراء بالدراسه
والتحليل في هذا السياق نشرت مجله فورين
افيرز الامريكيه مقالا رصد اسباب تنام
التشدد في مصر مستخلصا ان التطرف ليس الا
نتاجا للقمع تدليلا على ذلك يرد المقال
حادثه تفجير الكنيسه البطرسيه في القاهره
ديسمبر الماضي ف الانتحاري منفذ الهجوم
محمد شفيق مصطفى اعتقل عام
2014 عندما تصادف مروره مع مظاهره
للمعارضه فسجن لمده عام وعذب دون اتهام
حقيقي ومن ثم بات الشاب لقبه سائغه
لتستقطب الجماعه
المتشدده حالات كثيره مماثله تؤكد ارتداد
استراتيجيه السيسي لمكافحه الارهاب عكسيا
فالسجون باتت فضاءات لصناعه التطرف الذي
يبدو ان النظام يدفع اليه المعتقلين دفعا
بتعذيبهم وحبسهم ظلما في كثير من الاحيان
منذ انقلاب الثالث من يوليو
2013 وما رافقه من عنف للدوله وقمع
اجهزتها غير المسبوق للاحتجاجات السلميه
ارتفعت وتيره الهجمات وشدتها وبالتالي
ضحاياها كما تعددت امضاءات منفذيها مدفوعه
بتوسع مشهد الخصومه بين النظام ومواطنيه
وتذكر بعض الاحصاءات ان قتل الهجمات بلغ
خلال عام 2015 وحده 600 و 622 شخصا اي
بزياده قدرها
260 في عن عام
2014 في الصوره يبدو تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه وذراعه المعروفه بولايه سيناء
التي تستهدف هجماتها غالبا الجيش وقوات
الامن كما ظهرت خلال سنوات حكم السيسي
مجموعات عنف اخرى تختلف مع تنظيم الدوله
كحركه حسم وجماعه اجناد مصر وحركه مولوتو
ولواء الثوره وغيرها جماعات وجدت في
انسداد الافق السياسي منطلقا لنشاطها
فعملت على اجتذاب اولئك الذين تعرضوا لقمع
النظام او الذين فقدوا اقارب منذ الانقلاب
في مجزره فض اعتصامي رابعه والنهضه او في
حوادث القتل خارج القانون التي تلت تلك
الاحداث نظام السيسي وبدلا من ايجاد وظائف
للشباب العاطل عن العمل وتحسين اوضاع
ملايين المصريين القابعين تحت خط الفقر
اتجه نحو تشيد سجون جديده ورفع الاسعار
وفرض الضرائب جنبا الى جنب مع خنق الحريات
والتنكيل بالمعارضين والاصرار على الخيار
الامني دون سواه رغم تاكيد الخبراء انه
خيار يعمق ازمه مصر ويفاقم
استنزافها ينضم الينا من لندن عمر عاشور
استاذ الدراسات الامنيه والعلوم السياسيه
في جامعه اكستر البريطانيه وفي الاستديو
ينضم الينا احمد سالم الاكاديمي والباحث
المختص بالشان السينوي وابدا مع عمر عاشور
من لندن سيد عاشور الجماعات المسلحه في
مصر هل تشكل منظومه واحده و باهداف واحده
ايضا ولكن برايات
متعدده
لا هي بلا شك ليست منظومه واحده يعني هي
لها ايديولوجيات متعدده الاهداف ربما
يلتقوا في هدف رئيسي وهو عداوه النظام من
ناحيه يلتقوا ايضا في
طريقه طريقه التجنيد وهي تعتمد بالاساس
على يعني الراغبين في الانتقام من النظام
او الذين يعني كانوا في فتره ما ضحايا له
عبر الانتهاكات هم يعني يسعون لهذه
الشريحه لتجنيد م والاستخدام غضبهم في
حراكهم المسلح لكنهم يعني يختلفون فيما
يخص ال هيكل التنظيمي فيما يخص القدرات
التسليح فيما يخص اطار القياده والسيطره
فيما يخص الايديولوجيه فيما يخص الخطاب
يختلفون كثيرا يعني خطاب ولايه سيناء يعني
مفعم بالسفيه الجهاديه من ناحيه لديها
قدرات تسليحه الى حد ما غير مسبوقه سواء
في القاهره او في الدلتا او في الصعيد
تستطيع تستخدم صواريخ موجهه تستخدم مدفعيه
خفيفه
جماعات مثلا حركه حسم مثلا ادانت تفجير
مثلا كنيسه الكنيسه الذي حدث منذ شهرين
تقريبا ى حد ما كما راينا في الاصدار
الاخير قدراتها بسيطه يعني تعتمد على ما
يسمى مغاوير المدن
يعني بنادق اليه مسدسات عبوات محليات
الصنع فيعني والخطاب الموجود لديها هو
خطاب يجمع بعض الرموز الدينيه فيه ولكن
ايضا الكثير من الرموز القوميه او الوطنيه
تسمي نظام احتلال عسكري ولا تسميه مرتدون
مثلا ك
ارد فالخطاب مختلف هنا الى حد كبير نعم
اذا اردنا سيد عمر عاشور ان نلخص باختصار
شديد ابرز هذه الحركات المؤثره او
الجماعات المسلحه المؤثره حاليا في مصر
بمن يمكن
اختصارها نعم هو ابرزهم بلا شك ولايه
سيناء يعني ولايه سيناء
هي مغاوير تقليديين يعني اذا اردت يعني
كلاسيك انسجن هي تضرب في مناطق بعيده عن
عن سيطرا النظام في في في مناطق مهمشه
كسينا تستخدم الجغرافيا الى حد ما لصالحها
تستخدم نوعا ما من ربما تعاطف بعض
المحليين هناك لصالحها تستخدم الخبره
الطويله لان يعني ازمه سيناء تعود لاكثر
من 15 عاما لكن توجد جماعات صغيره ايضا
تختفي يعني حاله اجناد مصر مثلا انهارت
الحركه ربما ا لكن بسبب ان البيئه تنتج
المزيد من التنظيمات المسلحه وتنتج المزيد
من العنف ستتولد حركات صغيره اخرى وربما
تؤثر وربما تختفي بعد ذلك لكن البيئه ستظل
تنتج مثل هذه الحركات العنيفه امم يعني
هذا
ا يعني
بانها جماعات داخليه بحت وليس لها من
يمولها خارجيا ربما س سنعود الى هذه
النقطه بالتحديد لكن قبل ذلك سيد احمد
سالم وانت مختص ب بالشان السيناوي لماذا
يعني كثير من الحركات التي يشتد عودها من
الجماعات المسلحه في مصر تتركز في سيناء
ويكون عملها في هذه المنطقه الامر متعلق
بالبيئه الحاضنه لهذه التنظيمات ممارسه
النظام الحالي او حتى الانظمه السابقه في
سيناء التي همشت واهملت سيناء بشكل كبير
ا هناك غياب تام للدوله من الناحيه
التنمويه او الاقتصاديه في سيناء انتشر
البطاله بالاضافه الى اتفاقيه كامب ديفيد
التي حرمت سيناء من وجود امني حقيقي
تقريبا ثلثين مساحه سيناء ليس بها تواجد
امني حقيقي كل هذه العوامل المجتمعه ادت
الى انتشار او سهوله انتشار العنف او
الجماعات المسلحه في سيناء جعلت من البيئه
خصبه لانتشار مثل هذه الحركات السؤال هنا
لماذا تلك الجماعات التي تنشا دائما تكون
ذات
فكر يعني ذات فكر اسلامي وليس هناك بسبب
هذه الاوضاع وهذه البيئه الخصبه هناك مثلا
جماعات مسلحه ب بافكار اخرى لماذا جماعات
مسلحه اسلاميه ا في ظني ان الامر ليس
مرتبطا بال الفكره الاسلاميه وخصوصا في
وقتنا الحالي حركه مثل حركه لواء الثوره
التي اغتالت العميد عادل رجائي في شهر
اكتوبر الماضي سميت سمت نفسها بلواء
الثوره حركه حسم التي اصدرت فيلما مصورا
منذ ايام يوضح حصادها من العمليات ضد
اجهزه الامن في الوادي
والقاهره تاخذ شعارا لها بسواعدنا نشعل
ثورتنا وبالتالي النظام الحالي بانتهاج
الممارسه الامنيه او الحل الامني كخيار
وحيد وغياب اي حلول شامله للمشهد الحالي
وتاميم كل المساحات السياسيه وا سياسه
العصا الغليظه ضد من شارك في ثوره يناير
او ضد من رفض رفض
كل ما يحدث بعد ثه سبعه ادى الى وجود مناخ
خصب جدا لانتشار مثل هذه الحركات وانا
استطيع ان اقول ان البيئه الخصبه الذي
تسبب فيها هو النظام وهناك مقوله شهيره
لموت سيونج زعيم الثوره الصينيه الذي قال
ان مقاتل حروب العصابات يجب ان ينتشروا
بين الناس مثل مثلما يسبح السمك في البحر
وانا اقول ان نظام السيسي خلق مثل هذا
البحر ليس فقط في سيناء ولكن في عموم مصر
سنتابع الحديث ولكن اود ان اتوقف بما اننا
كنا نحاول ان
نستجمع الحركات ونختصر نشير هنا مشاهدينا
الى ان الحركات المسلحه التي ظهرت بعد
الانقلاب في
مصر عديده من بين اهم تلك المنظمات حركه
سواعد مصر التي تبنت هجمات استهدفت عددا
من اعوان النظام السيسي ورجالاته وفضلا عن
اغتيال عدد من منتسبي الاجهزه الامنيه
اعلنت الحركه مسؤوليتها عن محاوله اغتيال
المفتي علي جمعه وعن محاوله اخرى لاغتيال
النائب العام المساعد زكريا عبد العزيز
حركه لواء الثوره برزت هي الاخرى كطرف
يقارع بالسلاح نظام السيسي واجهزته خصوصا
من خلال عمليه اغتيال العميد اركان حرب
عادل رجائي في اكتوبر الماضي وبرزت كذلك
من خلال عمليه كمين الاعجازي التي قتل
فيها امين شرطه واصيب خمسه اخرون المقاومه
الشعبيه فصيل م ح اخر تبنى مقارعه النظام
المصري غير انه توارى بعد عمليات استهدفت
مولدات كهرباء ومقار حكوميه بالحرق ويبقى
الهجوم على حافله صغيره تابعه للداخليه
ابرز هجماتها اذ خلف سبعه قتلى من الشرطه
يشار في السياق نفسه الى منظمه العقاب
الثوري التي تعود اخر عملياتها الى يناير
2016 وقد حاول النظام المصري تحميل هذه
الفصائل المسلحه مسؤوليه التفجير الذي
استهدف الكنيسه البطرسيه في ديسمبر الماضي
غير ان تنظيمي لواء الثوره وحسم اصدر
بيانين اكد فيهما ان منهجيه ما لا يسمحان
باستهداف المدنيين مهما كانت مواقفهم اعود
اليك سيد عمر عاشور من لندن قلت قبل قليل
بان هذه الج بعض الجماعات يظهر ثم يختفي
هذا يثير تسا
فضلا عن البيئه الخصبه هل هناك من يعمل
على ابراز هذه الجماعات او اظهارها في
مرحله سياسيه معينه ثم يعمل
على اخفائها او اندثارها بما انه لا حاضنه
خارجيه
لها لا انا لا اظن يعني انا اظن الازمه
محليه بحته اذا ما يحدث هو هو الاتي يعني
هذه الجماعات يعني في الدراسات الامنيه
ربما لدينا قانون لم يكسر بعد وان القمع
النظامي يؤدي العنف غير نظامي ا بمعنى ان
النماذج الشهيره الستريشن اجريشن الاحباط
المؤدي للعدوان هو الذي يحدث في مصر يعني
الى حد كبير تجد شباب انتهج في فتره ما
ويرى ان لا لا افق له في في ظل هذه البيئه
وبالتالي يتجه للعنف ولحمل السلاح لكن
خبراته في العنف يعني محدوده
قدراته محدوده تموينه محدود لا يوجد اطار
تنظيمي حقيقي يعني هو ينشئ نفسه بنفسه
يعني وبالتالي اجهزه الامن يعني تراهن على
القضاء عليه بسرعه وهو ما حدث مع بعض
الحركات يعني تم القضاء عليها بسرعه لكن
البيئه تنتج المزيد من الحركات يعني حركه
حسم الي قتل احد قادتها اقل من 25 سنه
يعني ف فرما شاب في
اي بئ اخرى سيكون غالبا في الجامعه او
يحضر الدراسات العليا بد من ان يحمل سلاح
ويقاتل سي عمر هناك هناك نظريه تقول دائما
و متداوله في اي في اوساط عده ان بعض هذه
الجماعات تكون مفيده او يسعى النظام
للاستفاده منها من اجل تقويه موقعه
ومواقفه ايضا والتشبث بالسلطه من خلال
تخويف الناس اي على الامن وانه هو الوحيد
الضامن لهذا الامن امن
المواطنين نعم هذا لا ين لا ينفي ذاك يعني
تتعدد المزايا من ناحيه يعني انت استمرار
وجود بيئه قمعيه لا يحترم فيها القانون لا
توجد فيها اليات مراقبه ومحاسبه على
الاجزه الامنيه والعسكريه باستمرار تفشي
الظلم والقمع طبعا سينتج لد اجس الام
معروف ذلك انه سينتج رده فعل لكن سيتم
القضاء على رده الفعل لانها ليست بالقوه
الكافيه فيها لقلب الميزان لصالحها فهذا
من ناحيه لكن يوجد ايضا استغلال سياسي
لرده الفعل هذه فعني البعض توجد بعض نظرات
المؤامره التي لها يعني تاريخ في يعني
حوادث التفجيرات التي حدثت في 54 تحديدا
وقت عبد الناصر تم يعني القاء اللوم على
عبد الناصر لانه كانت من من من فعل داخل
النظام ليستمد والان طبعا شرعيه مكافحه
الارهاب هي شرعيه هائله يعني دعني اعود
الى السيد احمد سالم
اريد هنا ان اسالك سيد احمد سالم عن طبيعه
رد النظام على هذه الجماعات المسلحه وما
الذي ينتجه في المقابل طبيعه الرد النظام
الحالي نظام يتعامل بلغه السلاح وفقط هذه
السياسه السياسه التي انتهجها منذ ثلاثه
سنوات و بعد احداث ثلاثه سبعه لم تنتج الا
ما نراه الان هذه الجماعات ليست لا تنطلق
من منطلقات دينيه اذا ما قرناها مثلا
بتنظيم الدوله في سيناء الذي ينطلق من
منطلق ديني بحت يعتبر الجيش والشرطه
كمرتين يعني مرتبط ارتباط وثيق بتنظيم
دولي يعمل في الخارج بينما التنظيمات التي
في القاهره الان هي تنظيمات محليه مجموعه
من الشباب الذي اعتقد في الحل العنيف فقط
اشكرك
جزيلا سالم واشكر عمر عاشور من لندن